कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाले हैं सबसे महत्वपूर्ण जर्मन
कंस्ट्रक्शन में से एक जर्मन कि इस मैंने
ऐसे बहुत सारे लोग देखे हैं जो मेरे पास
आते हैं और कहते हैं बाकी सब जर्मन खराब
बर्ताव तो समझ में आता है पर यह देर का
यूज करना है तनु का में यूज करने दम का
यूज करना हमको समझ में नहीं आता इसका मेन
कारण है कि वह सिस्टेमेटिक लिए समझकर नहीं
सीकर है पर आज हम इसे बहुत सरल तरीके से
समझ कर सीखने वाले हैं और मैं आपको बताता
हूं कि आज का जब यह वीडियो खत्म हो जाएगा
तो आपको कैसे यूज किया है और उसका यूज
कैसे करना है वह आपको समझ में आएगा वैसे
यह कंसेप्ट थोड़ी सी बड़ी है इसे और इसमें
प्रीपोजिशंस भी लेने वाले हैं तो इसीलिए
हमने इसके तीन पाठ बनाए हैं पर इस पाठ के
बाद आपको किस कंपलीटली समझ में आ जाएंगी
तो करते हैं शुरू सबसे पहले यह केस केस है
क्या जो सब लोग बोलते
ए सिंपल हिंदी में जो विभक्तियां है वहीं
जर्मन में कैसे है हिंदी में आपने देखा है
प्रथम द्वितीय तृतीय चतुर्थी ऐसे आज भी
व्यक्ति हैं हमने कि इस किरदार ने किरदार
को किरदार से यह सब व्यक्ति हैं यह क्या
करते हैं यह किसको होती है नाम को या
सर्वनाम को और वह क्या सिखाती हैं कि वह
तुम्हारा जो नाम है यह नॉन है वह उस वाक्य
में क्या काम करता है उसका काम क्या है
क्या वह करता है क्या वह कर्म है या वह
इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट है यह वह विपत्तियां
बताते हैं जर्मन में भी सेम है जर्मन में
तो सिर्फ चार व्यक्ति हैं कि चाय उसमें 34
हैं नेटिव वह तो हम मतलब को ज्यादा यूज भी
नहीं होती और वह अमेज्ड टो के बाद ही
सीखते हैं तो हम को आप सीखनी है सिर्फ तीन
सिर्फ तीन नॉमिनेटिव आपको ट्यून और डालते
हुए सिंपल है न कुछ भी नहीं है
कि पहले देखते हैं कि नॉमिनेटिव को ट्यूब
नाम तो बहुत बड़े लग रहे हैं क्या एकदम
सिंपल है अगर तुम किसी सेंटेंस में अगर
तुम किसी सेंटेंस मैं तुम्हारा नाम मन
करता है करता मतलब सब्जेक्ट है तो तुम
नॉमिनेटिव ओके मतलब केदार आम खाता है कौन
खाता है किरदार तो इधर नॉमिनेटिव है
कि क्या खाता है आम खाता है तो आम क्या है
करण तो वह सुधरते हुए करता है तो उन्होंने
राशियों कर्म है तो अपुन जटिल और ऐसे कुछ
वाक्यों होते हैं इसमें और एक करना होता
है इसको हिंदी में संप्रेषण या फिर
इंग्लिश में इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट बोलते
हैं केदार ने ओवी को अंजाम दिया कर्ता कौन
है किरदार कर्म कौन है आम वह क्या है
इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट यह जो इनडायरेक्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट है वह डर्टी है एकदम सिंपल तो वह
जो बड़े-बड़े बॉयज का डर निकल गया अगर तुम
को लगता है सब्जेक्ट हो तो तुम नॉमिनेटिव
हो अगर तुम कर्म हो तो तुम अपनी ड्यूटी हो
और अगर तुम इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट तो तुम
डरते हो एकदम सिंपल ओके अब हम थोड़ा कर
जाते हैं अब यह बहुत अच्छी कर सकते जो
मुझे मेरी फेवरेट क्योंकि वह सेम है हमारी
हिंदी से तो वह क्या है कि इंग्लिश में
अगर आप देखो तुम्हें जो सारी निर्जीव
वस्तुओं
है उनका जो जेंडर होता है वह निरुत्तर हो
जाता है पर हमारे हिंदी में ऐसा नहीं है
हमने निर्जीव वस्तुओं को भी पुलिंग और
स्त्रीलिंग दे दिया है जैसे मेरी किताब या
मेरा कमरा जर्मन में भी ऐसा ही है कि
अच्छी निर्जीव वस्तुओं है जिनको चमन ने
भून लेंगे इसलिए न्यूट्रल बना लिया है अब
इसमें दो चीजें ध्यान रखने जैसी हैं सबसे
पहला मेरा फेवरेट है यह आगे बस और ट्रक बस
और ट्रक दोनों अपने लिए इंग्लिश दोनों के
साइज उनका वेट और मोड सेम है पर बस को
अपने लड़की बना दिया फीलिंग बना दिया और
ट्रक को खुलेंगे बना दिया बस आती है ट्रक
आता है क्यों हमने नहीं पूछा पूछा हमने
नहीं या फिर मेरी किताब क्यों मेरा कमरा
क्यों कभी पूछा नहीं वैसे ही जर्मन में भी
किसी निर्जीव वस्तु का जेंडर में है फीमेल
ए न्यूट्रल
कि वो क्यों है यह पूछने में कोई मध्य
दिनों मीनिंग हुई संजय दत्त दूसरी चीज
मतलब मैं खुद मराठी भी जानता हूं तो हिंदी
में जो घड़ी है घड़ी है वह स्त्रीलिंग है
पर वही घड़ी मराठी में घड़ी लाड न्यूट्रल
बन जाती है यह टर्म बन जाती है अभी तक
मराठी हिंदी में इतने सारे शाम में है
दोनों संस्कृत से आती है दोनों की लिपि
सेम है फिर भी जो चीज हिंदी में
स्त्रीलिंग की है वह जर्मन तो वहीं मराठी
में जाकर नपुंसकलिंग की बनेगी तो कोई चीज
आ कर हिंदी में अगर कूलिंग के है तो जर्मन
में पुलिंग के हो ऐसी अपेक्षा करना गलत है
समझे यह दो चीजें सिंपल याद रखनी है कि
वहीं जर्मनी में भी हिंदी की तरह ही
निर्जीव वस्तुओं को अलग जेंडर हो सकते हैं
और हिंदी का जो चैनल है वह जन्म में हो यह
जरूरी नहीं समझ में आया सबको मैं कोई
ज्यादा देता हूं कि क्यों बहुत सारे लोग
इसमें जो गलती करते हैं कि क्या
हेलो कि आप ऐसे भी न अवॉर्ड सीखने वाले को
जर्मन जवाब सीख रहे हैं वह तो नए शब्द
सीखने वाले हो तो उसके साथ उसका जेंडर भी
सीख लो ऐसे अधिक कुछ लोग आपको मिलेंगे या
कहीं कुछ वेबसाइट आपको दिखेगा कि मैं एंड
होता है तो वह स्त्रीलिंगी है पर वह सारे
शॉर्टकट से उसमें कुछ मजा नहीं अगर आप कोई
चीज नहीं भाषा सीख रहे हैं तो उसको
रिस्पेक्ट देखिए इस सीखना चाहिए तो हम
क्या करेंगे जब नया वर्ष सीखेंगे उसके
जेंडर के साथ ही सीखेंगे तो यह ली है पहला
आपको समझ में आया कि नॉमिनेटिव पूजा ट्यूब
क्या है कि वह तुम्हारा जो नॉन है उसका
क्या रोल है तुम्हारे वाक्य में और
तुम्हारा खोजशब्द है वह पुल्लिंग
स्त्रीलिंग किया न्यूट्रल हो सकता है यह
चीज है अगर क्लियर है तो अभी हम सीखेंगे
एक्चुअली यह कैसे यूज कैसे करने हैं
बेसिकली बगैर दास है क्या यह पीस हम
सीखेंगे
कि आपके खत तो इंग्लिश में होता है दबा ऑल
द क्या है डिफरेंट आर्टिकल डेफिनिटिव मतलब
क्या मुझे पता है वह क्या है जब बॉडी द
बॉय अगर हम सबको पता है अब इंग्लिश में
चीज कोई भी हूं वही होता है बहुत ही है तो
वह एंगल भी यह तो तय है और अगर बेबी भी है
तो भी दत्त जर्मन में ऐसे नहीं है जर्मन
में वह दो के रूप बन जाते हैं दर्द देते
दाम दर वह कैसे बनते हैं तो जो पहली चीज
जो हमने सीखा कि उस अननोन का सेंटेंस में
काम किया है और दो
कि वह खुद जिम्मेदार है पेमेंट है या न
करूं तो वह हम एक टेबल की मदद से सीखेंगे
यह बर्फ ऊपर दिख रहा होगा एकदम सिंपल है
मैं बोलता हूं यह आईडिया एकदम सिंपल है
पांचवीं कक्षा की गणित जैसी है सिर्फ देखो
एक टेबलेट 354 व टेबल है उसको दो एक्सटेंड
तो यह टेबल अहम समझ लेते हैं पहले इस पर
अगर आप देखोगे तो क्या है पुल्लिंग
स्त्रीलिंग की नॉट रूल या प्लूरल मतलब
मेल-फीमेल नोट रम्य प्लूरल अभी अच्छी बात
है कि मैं लूं
कि उसका जो कैमरा जो
कि वह हमेशा एक ही चेतक यह करेंगे तो वह
डोंट ऊ हैव हमको बाकी फिर तीन और चीज
देखने की जरूरत नहीं है तो एक एक्सेस पर
हो गया मेल-फीमेल न्यूटन प्लूरल दूसरे इस
पर क्या है दूसरे इस पर है उसका काम क्या
है करता नो मेरा टेबलेट कर अकोर्डिंग और
इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट है तो टाइम यह
त्रिफला फोंटेन समझ में आया थ्री फोर टेबल
अब उसके जो कंटेंट फ्रॉम इतनी बार यूज
करने वाले हैं कि वह आप इजीली आपको याद
रहेंगी वो अपना मंत्री बन जाता है वह
सीखेंगे हादसे पर एक बार मंत्र बोल लेते
चलो मेरे साथ बोलो
कि द धोइए द धोइए
220 विदाउट बीइंग डैम ड्रॉप अधेड़ अब इसका
यूज कैसे करना है हम तो आपसे विनती है कि
कागज और मेरे साथ शेयर कीजिए फिर सेंटेंस
हम बनाएंगे सेंटर में कैसे करें करें
का पहला सेंटेंस लेते हैं उससे पहले हम
चार वर्ड जर्मन के सीख लेते हैं जो हमको
आसानी होगी पहला है बॉल बॉल या फिर जन्म
इसको बोलते हैं बाल बाल धो यह जर्मन में
वॉइस मेल पुलिंग गीत
हुआ था वह अव्वल मतलब घड़ी हमने सीखा है
जर्मन में स्त्रीलिंग है
हेलो हाउ टो यह हमको पता है अल्टो मतलब
कार अगेन देखो आओ टो इंस्टल और टोनिंग
गोला जो लिखोगे वहीं बोलोगे अब टुनग टो
न्यूट्रल और उसका प्लूरल बन जाता है अलटोस
अलटोस और एक और वर्ल्ड सीखते हैं रोड मतलब
लाल रेड कि हमको सेंटेंसेस बनाने में आसान
है
को लिखित तौर पर हम सेंटेंस बनाना शुरू
करते हैं मेरे साथ आप विष्णु करो ओके खा
और तब मैं हमेशा हर बैच को बोलता हूं आपको
भी यही बोलूंगा का यह स्टेप्स हमेशा फॉलो
करना जब आप की जजमेंट साथ जैसे-जैसे मैंने
छह-सात साल जर्मन ठीक है तो मैं यह सड़क
से डिलीट कर सकता हूं पर जब आप नए हो
भूलना नहीं स्टेप बाय स्टेप करना जो स्टेप
बाय स्टेप करें का या उसको हमेशा कर दिया
है कायम करोगे गलती होगी चम्मच स्टेप बाय
स्टेप ठीक हैं शुरू करते हैं द गॉड इज
ग्रेट द बॉल इस रेड तो फिर यहां पर हमको
इसको रिप्लेस करना है दरद अब तो उसकी नीचे
हम ढूंढ ढूंढ कर लेंगे अब यह धप्पा बोल इस
सेंटेंस में क्या है अगला तो क्या है
कि करता करता तो करता मतलब सब्जेक्ट इसलिए
आप उसके नीचे लिखोगे S8 और सब्जेक्ट और
सब्जेक्ट है तो कौन सी गैस है नॉमिनेट हुए
इसी लिखोगे नॉमिनेट हुई और खुद गेम क्या
है जर्मन में मेल पुलिंग गीली तो इसी
लिखोगे ए स्प्लैश एंड स्लैश एवं ओके और
अपना टेबल सिगरेट आपको उसमें देखो
नॉमिनेटिव मेल क्या है इंटरसेक्शन देर
इसीलिए हो गया डेढ़ बाल डिस्ट्रॉयड एकदम
सिंपल ऐड आखिर करेंगे तो आपको समझ आ जाएगा
नेक्स्ट करते हैं जब और चीज लें फिर सेंटर
लाइन होगा 1000 को होगा फिर से कड़ी यहां
पर सब्जेक्ट है एस एन फॉर मम्मी नाट्यम और
खुद घड़ी क्या है जर्मन में फीमेल इसीलिए
स्प्लैश टेंस लैब और नॉमिनेटिव कीमत क्या
है देखो प्रकट हुए दी
है तो क्या होगा दीवार इस ट्रीटमेंट सिंपल
कार्य अवधि तक प्रेम अग्न दक्षिण चैनल ऐड
करेंगे हम सब्जेक्ट नॉमिनेटिव कार्य
न्यूट्रल नॉमिनेटिव न्यूट्रल है हमारे
दांत दांत टो डिस्ट्रॉय हो गया है
[संगीत]
12 पास है तो कार्य कर रहे हैं अगले कार
अधिक हो गया प्लुरल तो जो के नीचे क्या
लिखोगे सब्जेक्ट नॉमिनेटिव लुट और
नॉमिनेटेड क्या होता है इसीलिए होगा दी
अवधेश सिंह रोड होगा क्योंकि बहुत रोड में
को कुछ नहीं उसका जवाब में काम है और उसका
जेंडर इसके मोड बंद देख रहे हैं अब आते
हैं हम में करता है तो इसीलिए फिर से कॉल
करो कि करो कर दी अब इसे चेक इसीलिए वह
कौन सी है और ट्यूमर खुद है कि
कि इस खबर दे रब्बा इश्क खबर दैनिक समझा
सबको पहले डर बल्कि उस सब्जेक्ट है कि
वैसे ही आए हैं उर्जा वॉच फिर से डॉक्टर
लाइन करेंगे और चेक अकोदा क्यों फीमेल
वॉइस मेल अकुंठ पति है इसलिए होकर इस हां
बदी मोर
एक विशेष आ है वह दौड़कर फिर से दक्षिणी
Channel and लोकाय आपको रिजल्ट यू नो
ट्रूम ट्रूम ट्रूम क्या है द इस चैप्टर
दावा ठोक कर कहते हैं आए हैं अनअदर कार
i20 कार के नीचे लाइंस ऑफ अकाउंट यह कुछ
इस तरह की टो सिंपल है न
मैं सिर्फ आपको क्या करना है दो एक्ट्रेस
है एक्सेस पर काम किया है वह खुद किया है
सिर्फ एक्सेस जोड़ों अपको अपका टेबल मिल
जाए अभी थर्ड जो है जो हमने देखा किरदार
ने ओमी को बांध दिया इसमें obd2 है ऐसे
बहुत कम सेंटेंस होते हैं किसी भी भाषा
में तो हम क्या करेंगे हम्म उसको और सिंपल
तरीके से ड्यूटी उसी रखेंगे तो जर्मन में
जो प्रपोजिशंस होते हैं प्रपोजिशन वह तरफ
उस आईटी अपीयर्ड ठाट ई होते हैं इसीलिए यह
2030 हो सकते हैं इसीलिए हमने अब तक
पोजीशन ठीक है नहीं हम तीसरी क्लास में
इसी के तीसरी क्लास में प्रपोजिशन सीखेंगे
तो फिर सबसे इंपोर्टेंट प्रपोजिशन व हम आज
सीखते हैं वह विथ विथ मतलब जब मन में मिट
कि मैं
अच्छा ठीक है तो यह जो मिट है डाक्टरों का
पोजीशन है तो डाक्टरों पर पोजीशन मतलब
क्या इसके बाद जो भी नौ आएगा उसको ट्यूब
बनाएंगे क्लियर है तो हमें करके देखते हैं
कि आई विल प्ले विद थे बॉल आईएस ए प्लेस
विद अबोव ऑल फ्रंट्स को करेंगे दलों को
करेंगे नोएडा लैंड कर दी अभी देखो उससे
पहले बिटिया फीट आया था तो इसलिए द कि
निकलेंगे डिपॉट हुई और बिल्कुल किया है
मेल तो डाट इव आफ में क्या होगा देखो अपने
टेबिल में डैम इस चीज पेन किलर मिनट दम
उबाल अगर आप देखोगे तीनों सेंटेंस पहली
बार जब अब क्या था खैर बाल स्ट्रेट फिर
ख्वाइश मोहब्बत दिन बाद और अभी हो गया इस
पिलर मिनट डेंबा ड्रॉन इन बदलता गया क्यों
बदलता गया ऐसे नहीं बदला क्योंकि उसका बाल
कला उस सेंटेंस में का रंग बदल सकते है
क्लियर सबको अब हम नैक सेंटेंस देखेंगे यह
सेंटेंस इसको समझ में आया ना उसको किस
कि चलो आई प्ले विथ द व्हाट आईएस प्लेसिड
दबोच द कॉलिंग करो पहले क्या है विद इसलिए
डाइजेस्टिव डिप वॉच क्या है फीमेल डू
फीमेल क्या है जाकर देखो
कुछ देर इसीलिए होगा इश्क लिमिट क्रॉस पर
यहां पर सबसे लोकप्रिय क्यों क्योंकि बहुत
सारे लोगों को आदत है कि वह क्या करते हैं
कि नया सीखते हैं वर्दी वर्दी करके तो
इससे उनके दिमाग में आया तो वह यहां पर
सर्टेनली वह रखते हैं उनके बारे में कैसे
बनाते हैं समझ लो वक्त मेल-फीमेल का
डाइजेस्टिव का रूप है वह इसीलिए मैं हमेशा
करूंगा हमेशा रहे हो तो वह फीमेल SSC को
अगर दूध व याद रखना है तो हमेशा याद रखना
समझा तो मैं औरत हूं तो यहां पर हम बोल
रहा है इस क्रम में वीरवार को समझ गया ना
क्वेश्चसं को नैक जाते हैं आईएफ बलकार
धोकर अगेन विद के कारण डिप लाश
कि डिप्रेशन ने को फिर से धूम है स्पीड
लिमिट डैम हाउ टो ऑल Dual को फिर से आते
हैं हम आईपीएल की दवा क्या करोगे आप
करेंगे जो कि चैनल लाइव विद है इसलिए
ट्यून ट्यून फ्लोरल डू फ्लोरल है दहन इश्क
पिलर मिडडे अल्टोस सिंपल अभियुक्त को
शांति से यह सारी के सेंटेंसेस दिखाई दे
रहे होंगे हर जगह उद्दीन दिखता है हम यह
कैसे किया तो उसका काम है करता है कर्म है
या विद के साथ है और वह मेघ है और हम
स्टेप बाय स्टेप करते बस कुछ भी नहीं है
कुछ समझ में आया है सबको अभी मैं बोलूंगा
कि आज आज आप यही बात सेंटेंस ठीक से समझ
लो नेक्स्ट क्लास में एक्सप्रेस में जब हम
सीखेंगे मैं और थोड़े वर्ड दूंगा और उनका
पुल्लिंग स्त्रीलिंग रूप दूंगा तो आप कर
पाओगे पर आज मुझे आपको ज्यादा कंफ्यूज
नहीं करना है तो आप क्या करो कि अभी आज
शुरुआत शुक्रिया उन्हें बहुत अच्छी
कांटेक्ट ठीक है वह कंसेप्ट और यह 12
सेंटेंस समझ लो आपको एटी परसेंट कैसे समझ
में आता है नेक्स्ट क्लास में नेक्स्ट
क्लास में हम जैसे बुद्ध मैसेजेस और
सीखेंगे और फिर मैं रहा तुम्हारा उसका
इसका करना सीखेंगे
अच्छा ठीक है तो वह जो वीडियो है वह मैं
दो दिन बार डालूंगा का यह अगर वीडियो आपको
देखना है और अगर आपको पता चलना चाहिए कि
वह वीडियो कब आ रहा है तो मेरी आपसे
रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप प्लीज मेरे चैनल को
सब्सक्राइब कीजिए और बेल आइकॉन को क्लिक
कीजिए जैसे कि जब मैं नया वीडियो डालूंगा
तो आपको नोटिफिकेशन मिल जाएगी तो जैसे
मैंने कहा मैं को फिर से रिक्वेस्ट करता
हूं कि कागज पर आप यह सब लिख लीजिए 12
सेंटेंस शांति से देख लीजिए आज हमने बेसिक
शॉट कैसे हमारे हो गए हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में हम इसको आगे लेकर जाएंगे मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट क्लास में दरियाबाद